Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History and we are looking at JFK, his assassination, the aftermath, the conspiracies and Dominic in the last episode. Kennedy was shot, killed and we left the episode on a cliffhanger. A policeman running into the book depository off Dealey Plaza from where the shots had come. Yeah. And meets a blank faced man on the second floor.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》，我们正在探讨肯尼迪总统、他的遇刺、后续影响、阴谋论以及多米尼克在上集提到的内容。肯尼迪被枪击身亡，我们在上集结尾处留下了悬念。一名警察冲进了迪利广场（Dealey Plaza）的教科书仓库大楼，枪声就是从那里传来的。是的。他在二楼遇到了一个面无表情的男人。
And the name of that man, Lee Harvey Oswald. Yeah. Meanwhile, the Kennedys are being rushed to Parkland, the best hospital in Dallas. Absolute trauma, bewilderment, chaos. Do you want to pick up the story where we left it off in the previous episode? I will do, Tom. You said Kennedy's shot and killed. I agree with you. I think Kennedy probably was killed at that moment, but he's not been proclaimed dead so the world does not know that he's been killed and indeed he is technically still alive at the point when the kennedy car so that was especially souped up armor-plated lincoln that we described last time not the first guy in the motorcade because
那个男人的名字叫李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德（Lee Harvey Oswald）。是的。与此同时，肯尼迪夫妇正被紧急送往达拉斯最好的医院——帕克兰纪念医院（Parkland Hospital）。那里充满了极度的创伤、困惑和混乱。你想从上一集结束的地方继续讲吗？我会的，汤姆。你说肯尼迪被枪击身亡。我同意你的看法。我认为肯尼迪当时很可能已经遇害，但他尚未被正式宣布死亡，所以全世界还不知道他已经死了。事实上，在肯尼迪乘坐的那辆车——也就是我们上次描述的那辆经过特殊改装、装甲加固的林肯轿车——到达时，他从技术上讲还活着。那不是车队里的第一辆车，因为
there are police cars ahead but they all rush to parkland hospital they get there at 12 37 on friday the 22nd of november 1963 so that is seven minutes after the first shot has rung out in Dealey Plaza. It's a terrible scene when they arrive. So John Connolly, the governor of Texas, a bullet has gone into his back. There is blood pouring from his kind of midriff. He is in horrendous pain. His wife, Nellie, who's been in the car with kennedys her thoughts are obviously with her husband rather than with the kennedys um so she's begging the paramedics
前面有警车，但他们都冲向了帕克兰医院。他们在1963年11月22日星期五下午12点37分到达那里，也就是迪利广场响起第一声枪响后的七分钟。他们到达时，现场惨不忍睹。得克萨斯州州长约翰·康纳利（John Connolly）背部中了一枪。他的腹部流血不止。他正处于极度的痛苦之中。他的妻子内莉（Nellie）当时和肯尼迪夫妇坐在同一辆车里，她的心思显然更多地放在丈夫身上，而不是肯尼迪夫妇身上。所以她一直在恳求医护人员
to give her husband attention he is lifted onto the stretcher in agony behind as secret service men and so on are sort of piling all around the car jacqueline kennedy is cradling her husband's body and in particular as you said last time in the previous podcast her husband's head kind of holding it together holding it together and she is refusing to move and to leave the car and actually it takes this agent Clint Hill who is the agent who had run up to the back of the car and jumped onto it in the chaos of the assassination he says please please Mrs., we must get the president to a doctor.
救救她的丈夫。他被抬上担架时痛苦不堪。在后面，特勤局特工等人正围在车周围。杰奎琳·肯尼迪（Jacqueline Kennedy）正抱着她丈夫的遗体，正如你上次在上一期播客中所说，她特别是在抱着她丈夫的头部，试图把它固定住，固定住。她拒绝离开那辆车。事实上，是克林特·希尔（Clint Hill）特工——也就是在刺杀混乱中冲向车尾并跳上车的那位特工——他说：“求求您，夫人，我们必须把总统送去见医生。”
And she says explicitly to him, no, Mr. Hill, you know that he's dead. Leave us alone. It's heartrending, isn't it? Because essentially she knows that this is her last chance to be with him, to hold him. Because once he goes into that trauma room, they're going to be cutting him up. She knows he's already dead. Yes. I think it's generally accepted among the
她明确地对他说：“不，希尔先生，你知道他已经死了。让我们待在一起。”这真是令人心碎，不是吗？因为从本质上讲，她知道这是她最后一次和他在一起、最后一次拥抱他的机会。因为一旦他进入急救室，他们就会对他进行解剖。她知道他已经死了。是的。我认为当时在车周围的人普遍都认为他已经死了，因为几秒钟后，副总统林登·约翰逊（Lyndon Johnson）的车就到了，特勤局特工围在他身边，他们已经在谈论要把总统带到安全的地方，而他们所说的总统是指LBJ。没错，是的。肯尼迪在四分钟内被迅速送入帕克兰医院的1号急救室进行紧急手术。帕克兰医院急救部门的主管当时不在。他去了得克萨斯州的加尔维斯顿，在一次会议上发表论文。当然，如果你有某种特定的心态，你可能会觉得这很可疑。尽管当然，很难看出这怎么可能是预先安排好的，即会议恰好在那时举行，而他
people around the car at that moment that he is dead because seconds later vice president linden johnson's car arrives and secret servicemen are around him and they're already agents already talking about getting the president to safety and by the president they mean lbj exactly yeah kennedy is whisked inside within four minutes minutes, he is in Trauma Room 1, a Parkland hospital, for emergency surgery. The head of emergency services at Parkland hospital is not there. He is away in Galveston, Texas, giving a paper at a conference. Of course, if you are of a particular mindset, you might say that's suspicious. Although, of course, it's hard to see how it could be really arranged, that the conference would be taking place and that he
恰好能在关键时刻发表关于他专业领域的论文。总之，他不在，但多名医生涌入。我的意思是，关于这个故事的一点是，那个房间，1号急救室，在所有不同的专家冲进去后，很快就变得极其拥挤。当然，里面也挤满了特勤局特工。这就是护士试图阻止杰基进入的时候吗？是的。发生了一场推搡，杰基强行闯了进去。她确实强行闯了进去。现场一片混乱。完全是混乱。我认为围绕这几个小时积累的许多怀疑，反映了这样一个事实：每个人都处于震惊之中。
would be able to give a paper on his specialism at the crucial moment. Anyway, he is away, but multiple doctors pile in. I mean, one of the things about this story is that that room, trauma room one, became absolutely packed very, very quickly as all the different specialists rushed inside. Of course, it's also full of Secret Service agents as well. And is this when the nurse tries to stop Jackie from going in? Yes. There's a kind of shoving match and Jackie forces her way in. She does force her way in. It's total confusion. It's total chaos. So much of the suspicion that has accumulated around these hours, I think, reflects the fact that everybody is in shock.
没有人知道发生了什么。没有处理这种情况的程序。没有处理此类事件的公式。即使有，它也会在现实的碰撞中分崩离析。虽然是1号急救室，但每个人都受到了创伤。再说一次，还是回到杰基身上，那个可怕的时刻，她递给护士一样东西，结果发现那是她丈夫的一块大脑组织。没错。是的。她一直把它拿在手里，汤姆。是的，这是一个非常、非常可怕的细节。他们立刻给肯尼迪做了气管切开术。
Nobody knows what's going on. There is no procedure. There is no formula for dealing with something like this. And even if there were, it would fall apart in collision with reality. And it's a trauma in one, but everyone is traumatized. Again, I mean, just sticking with Jackie, the terrible moment where she hands the nurse something and it turns out to be the chunk of her husband's brain. Correct. Yeah. And she's been holding it all this time. Cradling it in her hands, Tom. Yeah, it's a really, it's a horrible, horrible detail. Straight away, they give Kennedy a tracheotomy.
他们给他接上了麻醉机。但医生从他被推进来的那一刻起就很清楚，他已经死了，没有任何希望了。与此同时，在医院外，达拉斯警方调度员已经根据目击者关于窗边某人的多份描述，发出了嫌疑人的特征，这些描述来自在广场上与警察交谈的人。因为他们几乎都一致，除了一个人说那是一个黑人。没错。一个叫阿莫斯·尤恩（Amos Ewan）的少年，他说他认为枪声来自得克萨斯教科书仓库大楼顶层的正下方，而且他说可能是一个有色人种。
They hook him up to an anesthesia machine. But it is obvious to the doctors from the very moment that he is wheeled in he is dead that there is no hope now meanwhile outside the hospital the dallas police dispatcher has already sent out a description of the suspect based on the multiple eyewitness accounts of somebody at the window, the accounts that have been coming in from people talking to the police in the square. Because all of them pretty much concur, except for one guy who says that it's a black person. That's right. A teenager called Amos Ewan, who says he thinks the shot came from just underneath the top of the Texas Book Depository and probably a colored man, he says.
在那一点上，他们错误地将楼层定为五楼，因为那是三名黑人雇员所在的地方。是的，是的。但他们也数错了顶层下方的楼层数，因为他说就在顶层下方。大楼顶层下方的那一层是六楼。发出的嫌疑人描述如下：身份不明的白人男性，大约30岁，身材苗条，身高5英尺10英寸，体重165磅。据报道，他携带了一支被认为是.30口径的步枪。所以当我们讲到李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德时，听众将能够自己判断这与奥斯瓦尔德的吻合程度。所以警察正在搜捕这名嫌疑人。与此同时，回到1号急救室，
And at that point, they wrongly identify the floor as the fifth floor because that's where the three black employees had been yes yeah but they also miscount the number of floors beneath the top because he says it's just beneath the top the floor beneath the top of the building is the sixth floor the description of the suspect that goes out is as follows unknown white male approximately 30 slender build height 5 feet 10 inches weight weight 165 pounds. He is reported to be armed with what is thought to be a.30 caliber rifle. So when we get to Lee Harvey Oswald, listeners will be able to make up their own minds how closely that does or does not correspond with Oswald. So the police are searching for this suspect. Meanwhile, back in trauma room one,
15分钟后，肯尼迪的心脏最终停止了跳动。正如几乎所有的记录所说，毫无疑问，他在第三发子弹击中他头部的那一刻就已经死了。他被宣布死亡。来到医院的天主教神父被带了进去。他们为他做了临终圣事，其中一位对肯尼迪夫人说：“我非常肯定他的灵魂还没有离开他的身体。”是的。所以这是一次有效的临终圣事。然后神父们就出去了，不是吗？
15 minutes later, Kennedy's heart finally stops beating. As almost all accounts say, there's no doubt that actually he was dead at the moment that the third shot hit his head. He is proclaimed dead. Catholic priests who have come to the hospital are shown in. They give him the last rites, and one of them says to Mrs. Kennedy, I'm pretty certain that his soul had not yet left his body. Yeah. So this is a valid last sacrament. And so the priests then go out, don't they?
外面有成群的报社记者。其中一名记者问神父：“总统死了吗？”其中一位神父说：“他确实死了。”是的。所以这是传给世界的第一条肯尼迪死亡的确认消息。是的，这距离正式宣布还有相当长的一段时间。正式地。正式地，没错。
And there are crowds of newspaper men outside. And one of the journalists asks the priest, is the president dead? And one of the priests says, he's dead all right. Yes. And so this is the first confirmation going out to the world that Kennedy is dead. Yeah, and this is a considerable time before it is announced. Officially. Officially, exactly.
是的。回到迪利广场，下午1点06分，也就是肯尼迪被宣布死亡六分钟后，进入仓库大楼的达拉斯警官在六楼的窗边发现了一个所谓的“狙击手巢穴”。就好像有人在窗户周围用箱子搭建了一个小基地。他们发现了一个长长的棕色纸袋，那种可以装下一支步枪的袋子，他们还发现了三个用过的弹壳。他们此时没有发现武器。所以他们现在正在搜查仓库。因为实际上我们还没有说得克萨斯教科书仓库大楼
Yeah. Back in Dealey Plaza, at 1.06pm, so six minutes after Kennedy is proclaimed dead, the Dallas police officers who have gone up into the depository find, by the window in the sixth floor, what they call a kind of sniper's nest so it's as though somebody has constructed this sort of little base of boxes around the window they find a long brown paper bag the kind of bag that could conceivably store a rifle and they find three spent cartridge casings what they don't find at this point is a weapon. And so they are now scouring the warehouse. Because actually what we haven't said is what the Texas Book Depository
是什么。它是一家提供教科书的私营公司。里面全是书箱和架子之类的东西。是的。它就像一个迷你亚马逊，不是吗？是的。一个迷你亚马逊仓库。在仓库工作的人，他们的工作是：从楼下接订单，上楼，把书装进电梯，然后把电梯送下去，然后他们下来取下一批订单。所以就是这么简单。正如你所说，汤姆，它是一个原始的亚马逊仓库。所以他们正在搜查仓库寻找凶器。两分钟后，在1点08分，也就是枪击发生38分钟后，一个叫JD·蒂皮特（JD Tippett）的达拉斯警官，他曾经是二战中的伞兵，
is. It's a private company that provides school books. It's full of boxes of books and kind of shelves and stuff like that. Yeah. It's a kind of mini Amazon, isn't it? Yes. A mini Amazon warehouse. And the people who work in the warehouse, their job, they take orders from the bottom, they go upstairs, they load the books into the elevator, and then they send the elevator down, and then they come down to get the next set of orders. So it's as simple as that. Exactly as you say, Tom, it's a kind of proto-Amazon warehouse. So they are searching the warehouse for the murder weapon. Two minutes later, at later at 108 so with 38 minutes after the shooting a chap called jd tippett a dallas police officer who had once been a paratrooper in the
参加过突出部战役，现在为达拉斯警察局工作。他正开车穿过达拉斯市中心西南部的橡树崖（Oak Cliff）郊区。他看到一个男人走在街上，看起来非常鬼鬼祟祟、可疑，一边走一边回头看，在他看来，这个人的特征与嫌疑人的描述非常吻合。他开始开车跟着这个人，沿着街道跟踪他。三分钟后，在1点11分，就在东第10街和南帕顿大道的路口，一名目击者看到蒂皮特靠边停车，通过车窗与那个人交谈，尽管我们不知道他们两人说了什么。
second world war who had fought at the battle of the bulge who is now working for the dallas pd he is cruising through the suburban oak cliff, which is southwest of downtown Dallas, of the city center. And he sees a man walking along the street, looking very shifty and suspicious, kind of looking over his shoulder and stuff, who in his mind pretty accurately matches the description of the suspect. And he begins to kind of cruise after this guy to kind of tail him along the street. Three minutes later, at 1.11, just past the junction of East 10th Street and South Patton Avenue, an eyewitness sees Tippett pull over and talk to the man through the window of his car, though we don't know what the two of them say.
片刻之后，几名目击者看到蒂皮特下车走向那个人，就在那一刻，这个此时身份不明的男人掏出一把枪，将蒂皮特射杀。所以这发生在距离最初迪利广场枪击案发生地几英里远的地方。与此同时，在医院里，林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊（Lyndon Baines Johnson）被告知肯尼迪已经死了。有人问他是否应该向媒体宣布。他说：“不，我们不知道这是否是一场共产主义阴谋。”所以从一开始，
Moments later, several eyewitnesses see Tippett get out of the car and walk towards the man and it's at that point that this man unidentified at this point pulls out a gun and shoots Tippett dead so this has happened several miles away from where the original Dealey Plaza shooting happened meanwhile back at the hospital, Lyndon Baines Johnson has been told that Kennedy is dead. And he is asked whether or not they should announce it to the press. And he says, no, we don't know whether it's a communist conspiracy or not. So right from the beginning,
现场级别最高的人已经在考虑这个问题了。没错。而且不仅仅是他，因为11分钟后，联邦调查局（FBI）局长J·埃德加·胡佛（J. Edgar Hoover）打电话给特勤局局长詹姆斯·罗利（James Rowley）。顺便说一下，对于非美国人来说，特勤局不像英国的秘密情报局，特勤局实际上是保镖，是肯尼迪的安保人员。那些负责保护总统的人。他们讨论了刚刚发生的事情。他们显然像其他人一样处于震惊之中。两人都谈到了阴谋。所以特勤局的罗利问：“你认为可能是古巴吗？可能是古巴人吗？”胡佛说：“我不知道，
and absolutely the top most guy now on the scene is wondering about it. Exactly. And not just him him because 11 minutes later the head of the federal bureau of investigation the fbi j edgar hoover he rings the chief of the secret service james rowley secret service by the way for non-americans it's not like the british secret service secret service is effectively bodyguards it's security for kennedy. The guys who are looking after the president. And they discuss what's just happened. They're obviously in shock like everybody else. Both of them talk about conspiracies. So Rowley from the Secret Service asks, do you think it could be Cuba? Could it be Cubans? And Hoover says, I don't know,
很可能是三K党。”所以我们这里有三个主要的阴谋论：共产主义者、古巴、三K党，或者与右翼极端分子有关。是的。令人着迷的是，这些人处于美国政府的最顶层，他们的第一直觉是说：“好吧，这是阴谋的一部分吗？这是更广泛的事情吗？”在胡佛与特勤局那个人谈话一分钟后，在得克萨斯教科书仓库大楼，1点22分，达拉斯警官确实找到了凶器。他们在六楼的一些箱子下面发现了一支步枪。那是一支带有毛瑟枪机和廉价日本望远镜瞄准镜的步兵步枪。
it could well be the Ku Klux Klan. So there we have three of the main conspiracy theories, the communists, Cuba, the Ku Klux Klan, something to do with right-wing extremists. Yeah. It's fascinating that these are people at the very top of American government and their first instinct is to say, well, is this part of a conspiracy? Is this something wider? A minute after the Hoover's had that conversation with the secret service chap at the Texas Depository at 122, the Dallas police officers do find the murder weapon. They find a rifle that has been stuffed underneath some boxes on the sixth floor. It is an infantry rifle with the Mauser action and a cheap Japanese telescopic sight.
所以这是在枪击发生不到一小时后。他们发布了嫌疑人的描述。他们找到了弹壳。他们找到了他们认为是案发地点的地方，并且找到了他们认为是凶器的东西。所以要给达拉斯警方点赞。绝对的。他们工作做得非常好。而且非常快。
So this is less than an hour after the shooting has taken place. They have issued a description of the suspect. They have found the cartridge casings. They have found what they think is the place, and they have found what they believe is the weapon. So kudos to the Dallas police. Absolutely. They're doing their job very well. And very fast.
与此同时，警察也正前往JD·蒂皮特的谋杀现场，他们昔日的战友。电台也在发布这名嫌疑人的描述：白人男性，大约30岁，5英尺8英寸，黑发，身材苗条，穿着白色夹克、白色衬衫和深色长裤。所以他们现在正在搜寻可能是一起无关谋杀案中的第二名嫌疑人。但这与肯尼迪枪击案最初的嫌疑人警报非常吻合。
At the same moment, police are also heading to the scene of the murder of J.D. Tippett, their erstwhile comrade. The radio is also distributing a description of this suspect, a white male, about 30, 5'8", black hair, slender, wearing a white jacket, white shirt and dark slacks. So they are now searching for what could conceivably be a second suspect in an unrelated murder. But it corresponds quite closely to the original suspect alert from the Kennedy shooting.
确实。我认为任何公正的观察者都会说这些描述非常相似。回到医院，1点30分，我们在不同的地点之间切换。在1点30分，关于肯尼迪的遗体发生了一场激烈的争吵。因为达拉斯县法医已经到达，他说：“根据达拉斯法律，根据得克萨斯州法律，我们必须保留这具遗体进行尸检。”特勤局对此感到震惊，他们说：“不，我们必须立即返回华盛顿。”毫无疑问，法律站在达拉斯县法医这一边，肯尼迪的遗体本应留在
It does. I think any fair-minded observer would say they are pretty similar descriptions. Back at the hospital, 1.30, so we're switching between different locations. At 1.30, there is a furious, furious row going on about Kennedy's body. Because the Dallas County Medical Examiner has now arrived and he says, under Dallas law, under Texas state law, we have to keep this body for an autopsy the secret service are horrified by this and they say no we have to get back to Washington immediately there is no doubt that the law is on the Dallas County medical examiner's side that Kennedy's body should have stayed in
达拉斯进行尸检。同样，对于那些怀疑官方事件叙述的人来说，这非常奇怪且阴暗。但我认为这有一个相当合理的解释，汤姆。我推测解释是，如果肯尼迪的遗体必须留在那里，那么杰基就必须留在那里。嗯，他们都得留在那里。但特别是肯尼迪夫人。是的。
Dallas for an autopsy and again for people who are suspicious of the official narrative of events, this is very odd and very murky. I think there's a pretty reasonable explanation for it, though, Tom. I presume the explanation is that if Kennedy's body has to stay there, then Jackie will have to stay there. Well, they'll all have to stay there. But particularly Mrs. Kennedy. Yeah.
因为这里又出现了那个令人心碎的时刻，他们正要离开，她摘下结婚戒指，戴在她丈夫的手指上。然后她进行了这次对话：“我做对了吗？我想给他点什么。”一位助手回答说：“你就把它留在原处吧。”然后杰基·肯尼迪说：“现在我一无所有了。”是的。你可以看出人类的情感是其中非常、非常重要的一部分。
Because there's this, again, this heart-rending moment where she's, you know, they're about to go and she slips her wedding ring off and puts it on her husband's finger. And then she has this conversation. Did I do the right thing? I wanted to give him something. And an aide answers, you leave it right where it is. And then Jackie Kennedy says, now I have nothing left. Yeah. And you can see the human emotions are a very, very important part of this.
它们往往会被官方叙述所冲淡。确实如此。汤姆，我认为你说得完全正确。我认为他们对她感到无比同情。但当然，特勤局，从专业角度来说，他们迫切希望回到华盛顿特区，回到他们所认为的华盛顿特区的安全地带。如果这是一场阴谋，如果正如他们心中完全可能的那样，这是一场由古巴、莫斯科策划的阴谋，那么带着美国总统林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊待在达拉斯医院里，是一件疯狂的事情。
And they tend to get, I guess, washed out of official narratives. They do. I think you're absolutely right, Tom. I think they feel utterly horrified for her. But also, of course, the Secret Service, just professionally speaking, they're desperate to get back to Washington, D.C., to what they see as the safety and security of Washington, D.C. If this is a conspiracy, and if this is, as is perfectly possible in their minds, a conspiracy orchestrated from Cuba, from Moscow, then hanging around in a Dallas hospital with the President of the United States, Lyndon Baines Johnson, is a bonkers thing
他们需要尽快回去。在我们有生之年，最接近的类比是袭击世界贸易中心后随之而来的混乱、困惑和恐惧感。人们根本不知道发生了什么，但却担心最坏的情况。完全正确。认为他们会在那一刻说：“哦，当然，我们都会在这里待上几个小时。慢慢来，做尸检。”我的意思是，这显然是完全不可信的。他们训练中的一切、直觉和常识都在尖叫：“上飞机，回华盛顿特区。”
to do. They need to get back as quickly as possible. The closest analogy within our lifetimes would be the sense of chaos and confusion and terror that followed the attack on the World Trade Center. People having no idea what's going on at all, but fearing the worst. Exactly right. The idea that at this moment they would say, oh sure, we'll all hang around here for hours. Take as long as you like, do the autopsy. I mean, that's obviously utterly implausible. Everything in their training and in their instincts and common sense is screaming, get on the plane and get back to DC.
但我确实认为，对杰基·肯尼迪的焦虑、关心和怜悯是这件事的一个非常重要的方面。事实上，当我们谈到杰克·鲁比（Jack Ruby）时，这将是一个重要的方面。是的。她仍然穿着那套粉红色的套装。是的。她浑身沾满了她丈夫的血。她显然受到了创伤。
But I do think the anxiety, the concern, the pity for Jackie Kennedy is a really important aspect of this. And indeed will be an important aspect when we come to Jack Ruby. Yeah. That, you know, she's still wearing that pink suit. Yeah. She's drenched in her husband's blood. She's obviously traumatized.
我认为你必须有一颗非常冷酷的心，才不会想到她。还有他们的孩子。还有孩子们。他们还在华盛顿。认为他们会告诉她：“好吧，杰基，我们帮你订一家假日酒店。”
And I think that you'd have to have a very harsh heart. Right. Not to think about her. And their children. And the children. Who are back in Washington. The idea that they would say to her, well, Jackie, we'll book you into a holiday inn. Yeah.
“你可能要在这里待几天。”我的意思是，这显然是完全不可想象的。是的。顺便说一句，关于这件事的最后一件事，关于死亡的正式宣布——嗯，我的意思是，我说正式，向美国公众宣布的那一刻是1点38分，也就是这次谈话八分钟后。沃尔特·克朗凯特（Walter Cronkite），美国广播界的泰斗，在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）向全国宣布了这一消息。任何看过肯尼迪遇刺相关内容的人都会认出这段录像。他显然悲痛欲绝。
You might be here for a few days. I mean, that's obviously utterly unthinkable. Yeah. By the way, one last thing on this the official announcement of the death well i mean i say official the moment that it's broken to the american public is at 1 38 so that's eight minutes after this conversation walter cronkite who is the kind of dean of american broadcasting announces the news to the nation on cbs anyone who's ever seen anything to do with the canada assassination will recognize the footage. He's clearly grief stricken.
当他说“副总统约翰逊将飞回华盛顿”时，他摆弄着眼镜。他的声音有些哽咽，这是一个非凡的时刻。与此同时，回到橡树崖，一个在杰斐逊大道一家鞋店工作的人。当然，消息已经传遍了全城。所以每个人都处于震惊状态。他看到这个年轻人走在街上，行为非常怪异，一边走一边回头看，警车正从他身边疾驰而过。警察都涌进了一家图书馆，不是吗？是的，所以……有书的建筑是这个故事的一个特征。是的，是的。如果你在得克萨斯州喜欢读书，这就是你的故事。是的，约翰尼·布鲁尔（Johnny Brewer），鞋店经理，他看到这家伙
He fiddles with his glasses when he says Vice President Johnson will be flying back to Washington. His voice kind of breaks, which is this extraordinary moment. Meanwhile, back in Oak Cliff, a guy who works in a shoe shop on Jefferson Boulevard. Of course, the news has gone around the city. So everybody's in a state of shock he sees this young man walking along the street behaving very weirdly looking over his shoulder as police cars are kind of rushing past him the police are all panning into a library aren't they they are so uh buildings with books in they're a feature of the story yes yeah if you're bookish in texas this is your story yeah johnny brewer the manager of the shoe store he sees this guy
行为怪异，然后躲进了一家电影院——得克萨斯剧院（Texas Theater）。他想：“这都是些什么？”他跟着这个家伙，对售票员说：“那个人买票了吗？”她当时心不在焉。她说：“没有。”他说：“哦，我想我们应该报警。”警察来得非常、非常快，大约下午1点48分，他们进入了电影院。起初，带着悲喜剧式的讽刺，他们把枪对准了布鲁尔本人，那个鞋店的人。他说：“不，不是我，我是那个发现嫌疑人并向你们举报的人。”他指出了一个坐在倒数第三排的家伙。他们走过去包围了这个男人，必须说，他看起来非常像发出的关于射杀JD·蒂皮特的那名男子的两份描述，也像人们认为可能在得克萨斯教科书仓库大楼的那个人。他们确认了那个人并包围了他。那个人的反应，他说的第一句话是：“好吧，现在一切都结束了。”然后突然他猛地反击，发生了一场扭打。
behaving weirdly and then ducking into a cinema the the Texas Theater. And he thinks, what's all this? And he follows this bloke and he says to the ticket seller, did that guy buy a ticket? And she was distracted. She says, no. He says, oh, I think we should call the police the police arrive very very quickly about 1 48 p.m and they go into the cinema at first with tragicomic irony they pull their guns on brewer himself the shoe shop man and he says no it's not me i'm the guy who spotted the suspect tip you off tip you off and he points out a bloke who's sitting three rows from the back they go and they surround this man who looks it has to be said very like the two descriptions that were sent out of the man who shot jd tippett and also the man who people think may have been at the texas book depository they identified that guy and they surround him the guy's reaction the first thing he says is well it's all over now and then suddenly he lashes out there's a scuffle
他显然在伸手去拿枪，警察扑向他，发生了一场扭打和搏斗。所以这就是他身上出现淤青和黑眼圈的时候。黑眼圈，是的，没错。所以电影院地板上发生了一切小规模的搏斗。他们设法给他戴上手铐，然后把他拖到外面。当他们把他拖到外面时，他大喊着关于“我知道我的权利”之类的话，大喊“这是警察暴行，这太可怕了”。外面已经聚集了一群暴徒。别忘了，人们不喜欢杀警犯，这就是这个家伙被逼入绝境的原因。他被逼入绝境是因为他是射杀JD·蒂皮特的人，而不是射杀约翰·F·肯尼迪的人。是的，外面有人在喊“绞死他”，所有这些，真是个坏蛋，所有这些话。警察把他
he's clearly reaching for a gun and the police pile onto him and there's more of a scuffle fighting and so this is when he gets the kind of the bruises and the black eye and the black eye yes exactly so there's all this little fighting on the floor of the cinema they manage to handcuff him and then they drag him outside as they drag him outside he's shouting about his i know my rights kind of thing and shouting this is police brutality this is all terrible there's a mob already assembled outside people don't like cop killers don't forget that's what this guy has been cornered for he's been cornered as the man who shot jd tippett not the man who shot john f kennedy yeah there are people outside shouting hang him all this what a bad guy all this kind of thing and the police bundle him
塞进外面等候的车里，然后他们就走了。嫌疑人在车里时，突然似乎冷静了下来。他对他们说：“哦，有警察被杀了吗？”他们没有回答。然后他说：“我听说他们因谋杀而被烧死。”其中一名警官说：“好吧，你很可能会发现。”那家伙说：“好吧，他们说死只需要一秒钟。”汤姆，如果你是被冤枉的，这真是一句奇怪的话，对吧？是的。我认为这是现阶段要提出的一个关键点。
into the car waiting outside and then off they go the suspect when he's inside the car suddenly seems to calm down he says to them oh has a police officer been killed and they don't reply and then he says i hear they burn for murder and one of the officers says well you might well find out and the guy says well they say it just takes a second to die. Which is a kind of odd thing to say, Tom, if you've been wrongly accused, right? Yes. I think it's a key point to make at this stage.
我从未因我没犯过的罪而被警察逮捕，也没有被指控谋杀。但如果我被指控了，而我没有做，我当然会非常害怕，而且我想我会很渴望纠正记录，不是吗？我想我会的，是的。你会一直抗议你的清白。你不会有任何时候是冷静、退缩、阴沉的。开始谈论被电刑会是什么感觉。不，没错。我认为那不会是显而易见的谈话点。不，不。如果那真的发生了，汤姆，我的意思是，我会提醒你这些话。
I've never been arrested by the police for a crime I didn't commit, and nor have I been accused of murder. But if I were and I hadn't done it, I'd be very frightened, of course, and keen, I would imagine, to correct the record, wouldn't you? I think I would, yeah. You would be protesting your innocence at every point. There would be no point at which you were calm, withdrawn, sullen. Start talking about what it would be like to be electrocuted. No, exactly. That wouldn't be the obvious point of conversation, I think. No, no. And if that ever happens, Tom, I mean, I will remind you of these words.
当我走向电椅时。没错，正是如此。所以他们拿出他的钱包，在里面发现了两张卡，一张写着李·奥斯瓦尔德的名字，另一张写着A.G.海德尔（A.G. Heidel）的名字。这很关键，不是吗？这很关键。非常重要的线索。他们认为奇怪的是，此时这个家伙没有表现出任何情绪。这将是我们回归的一个主题。不到半小时后，2点15分，消息传到当地联邦调查局，那名
As I go to the chair. Right, exactly. So they take out his wallet and they find two cards in it, one in the name of Lee Oswald and the other in the name of A.G. Heidel. And this is crucial, isn't it? It is crucial. Very important clue. They think it is odd that at this point this guy is showing no emotion whatsoever. This will be a theme that we return to. Less than half an hour later, at 2.15, the news reaches the local FBI that the man
因射杀JD·蒂皮特而被捕的男子是一个叫李·奥斯瓦尔德的人。立刻，听到这个消息的人之一是联邦调查局特工詹姆斯·霍斯蒂（James Hostie）。我假设他姓氏是这样发音的。他说：“我有奥斯瓦尔德一家的档案。”他对他的主管说：“那一定是射杀肯尼迪的人。”他心中毫无疑问那就是射杀肯尼迪的人，因为正如我们将看到的，联邦调查局一直对奥斯瓦尔德感兴趣，因为他们认为他是极左翼分子。现在，与此同时，2点15分，肯尼迪遗体的争夺战终于赢了。
arrested for the shooting of J.D. Tippett is a man called Lee Oswald. And immediately, one of the guys who hears this information is FBI agent James Hostie. I assume that's how he pronounces his second name. He says, I have a file on the Oswalds. And he says to his supervisor, that must be the guy who shot Kennedy. There's no doubt in his mind that that is the guy who shot Kennedy, because as we will see, the FBI have been interested in Oswald because they regard him as somebody on the far left. Now, at the same time, 2.15, the battle for Kennedy's body has finally been won.
所以杰基、特勤局，整个随行人员。嗯，并没有完全赢，不是吗？因为据我所知，基本上，LBJ和安保部门以及所有人已经强行冲了出来，上了飞机。但他们一直很紧张，担心达拉斯执法部门可能会开着车追上来，闹出乱子。没错。他们确实很紧张。所以这是一种额外的危险维度。我的意思是，这正是他们不需要的。
So Jackie, the Secret Service, the whole kind of entourage. Well, it hasn't entirely been won, has it? Because as I understand it, basically, LBJ and the security service and everybody have bulldozed their way out and got onto the plane. But the whole time, they're nervous that the Dallas law authorities might come tearing up in their cars and kick up a fuss. That's right. They are. So that's a kind of extra dimension of jeopardy. I mean, it's just what they don't need.
会有尸检，但它会在华盛顿特区进行。那是贝塞斯达海军医院（Bethesda Naval Hospital）的管辖范围。与此同时，谈话内容是LBJ必须成为总统。他需要宪法权力。并且商定他将在起飞前宣誓就职成为总统。他们需要一位法官来做这件事。他说：“好吧，有一位叫萨拉·休斯（Sarah Hughes）的法官，她是他的老朋友，是一位联邦法官，某种客户。”所以他们正在等待萨拉·休斯到达。她在2点30分到达爱田机场（Love Field）。
There's going to be an autopsy, but it's going to happen back in Washington, DC. That's the remand of the Bethesda Naval Hospital. Meanwhile, the talk is LBJ must become president. He needs the constitutional authority. And it's agreed he will take the oath of office to become president before they take off. They need a judge to do it. And he says, well, there's this judge called Sarah Hughes, who's an old friend of his, who's a federal judge, a kind of client. So they're waiting for Sarah Hughes to arrive. And she arrives at 2.30 at Love Field.
八分钟后，宣誓就职仪式开始，这与美国历史上任何其他仪式都不同。所以这就是那张著名的照片，我们都看过这些照片。如果你看照片，你会看到中间的LBJ，必须说，他看起来处于完全震惊的状态，完全像丧家之犬。他身边有伯德·约翰逊（Lady Bird Johnson），她看起来同样悲痛。还有杰基，你知道，看起来像一个处于完全、彻底创伤状态的人，仍然穿着她那套沾满血迹的套装，仍然穿着那套套装，仍然穿着那套粉红色的套装。而这，汤姆，距离他们转入迪利广场、她丈夫还活着的时候，才过了两个半小时。事件的节奏之快。是的，它以如此快的速度进行，不是吗？
And eight minutes later, the swearing in ceremony begins unlike any other american history so this is the famous photograph we've all seen the photos if you look across the photo you have lbj in the middle you have to say shocked he looks in a state of total shock utterly hanged dog he has ladybird johnson on one side who looks similarly stricken and you have jackie who looks you know like somebody in a state of complete and utter trauma still in her blood-soaked suit still in the suit still in the pink suit and this tom is two and a half hours since they turned into dd plaza when her husband was still alive. The sheer pace of events. Yeah, it's moving at such a pace, isn't it?
任何经历过某种非常令人震惊的事件，或者，你知道，意外失去家庭成员，或者任何这些车祸，或者任何这类事情的人都会知道，你会觉得你被弹射进了一种平行现实。是的。突然间，整个世界都颠倒了，你处于一种混乱状态。但所有这一切发生得如此之快，压力如此之大，这真是一个不可思议的时刻。这个故事令人惊奇的地方在于，你有两条叙事线索并行。你有肯尼迪死亡被送往医院的恐怖，
Anybody who has ever been in a sort of very shocking incident or, you know, lost a family member unexpectedly or any of these car crash or any of these kinds of things will know that you feel you've been catapulted into a kind of parallel reality. Yeah. And suddenly the whole world has turned upside down and you're in a state of confusion. But for all this to have happened so quickly and unrelenting pressure, it's just an incredible moment. And the amazing thing about this story is the way that you have two narrative strands going in parallel. You have the horrors of Kennedy's death being taken to the hospital,
然后是高层政治的问题。事实上，这一切都关乎美利坚合众国的政府，世界上最强大的国家。与此同时，在达拉斯的街头，你有警察的调查。是的。而且，警察进行调查的速度要么非常令人印象深刻，要么可能非常阴险。我们无疑会谈到这一点。但也许我们应该在这一点上休息一下。所以LBJ正和肯尼迪的遗体在飞机上返回华盛顿，
and then the matter of high politics. The fact that this is all about the government of the United States of America, the most powerful country in the world. At the same time, out on the streets of Dallas, you have the police investigation. Yes. And again, the speed with which the police conduct their investigation is either very impressive or perhaps very sinister. We will undoubtedly get onto that. But perhaps we should take a break at this point. So LBJ is on the plane with Kennedy's corpse heading back to Washington
而李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德已经被警方拘留。当我们回来时，我们将找出接下来发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在
and Lee Harvey Oswald has been taken into police custody. And when we come back, we will find out what happens next i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are
达拉斯。现在是1963年11月22日，多米尼克，现在是三点钟，距离约翰·菲茨杰拉德·肯尼迪总统遇刺已经两个半小时了。达拉斯的警察在做什么？所以警察已经有了嫌疑人李·奥斯瓦尔德。他们还在他的钱包里发现了一张写着AJ·海德尔的卡片。他们已经把他带回了达拉斯市中心的警察总部。他们已经找到了他在达拉斯租住的房子。所以他平时在达拉斯过周，然后周末去郊区的欧文（Irving）看望他的妻子。
in Dallas. It is the 22nd of November 1963 and Dominic, by now it is three o'clock, two and a half hours after the assassination of President John Fitzgerald Kennedy. And what are the police in Dallas up to? So already the police, they have the suspect Lee Oswald. They also have a card in his wallet that says AJ Heidel. They've taken him back to police headquarters in downtown Dallas. They have already located the house where he boards in Dallas. So he spends the week in Dallas and then he goes to Irving in the suburbs to see his wife at weekends.
他们已经找到了他在橡树崖地区的寄宿公寓。几个小时内，他们就在搜查那所房子。它在北贝克利街（North Beckley Street）。所以他们发现了大量关于共产主义的书籍等等。很多。他们还发现了詹姆斯·邦德（James Bond）的小说，不是吗？是的。但如果你对共产主义感兴趣，你可能也会对詹姆斯·邦德感兴趣，汤姆。
They've located his boarding house in the Oak Cliff area. Within a couple of hours, they're searching the house. It's on North Beckley Street. And so they find lots of books on communism and so on. Loads. They also find James Bond novels, don't they? Yeah. But if you're interested in communism, you might also be interested in James Bond, Tom.
是的。你会是一个冷战迷，不是吗？或者如果你对射杀美国总统感兴趣，你可能会喜欢詹姆斯·邦德。那是真的。这一切都是真的。或者如果你对阴谋感兴趣。所有这些事情。由邪恶的超级恶棍经营，你可能会喜欢詹姆斯·邦德。那是真的。这一切都是真的。或者如果你对阴谋感兴趣。所有这些事情。由邪恶的超级恶棍经营，你可能也会喜欢。正是如此。我认为基本上每个人在1963年都喜欢詹姆斯·邦德。好吧。除了《新政治家》的
Yeah. You'd be a Cold War-ophile, wouldn't you? Or if you're interested in shooting US presidents, you might be into James Bond. That's true. That's all true. Or if you're into shadowy conspiracies. All of these things. Run by sinister master villains, you might be into James Bond. That's true. That's all true. Or if you were into shadowy conspiracies. All of these things. Run by sinister master villains, you might be as well. Precisely. I think basically everybody likes James Bond in 1963. All right. Except for the new
评论员保罗·约翰逊（Paul Johnson）。这是他读过的最淫秽的书。总之，那是题外话。那个地方到处都是关于苏联、关于共产主义的书籍。有小册子，有来自美国共产党、社会主义工人党的信件，还有很多来自“公平对待古巴委员会”（Fair Play for Cuba Committee）的东西，这是一个极左翼团体，声称美国对菲德尔·卡斯特罗（Fidel Castro）非常严厉等等。他们还发现了一本带有李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德名字和照片的苏联护照。这，你知道，我的意思是，那一定很令人震惊，因为那不是你通常期望在达拉斯发现的东西，对吧？不，不，一点也不。一个拥有苏联护照的美国公民。这对联邦调查局来说不会感到意外。但对
statesman's reviewer, Paul Johnson. It's the most obscene books he'd ever read. Anyway, that's by the by. The place is full of books on the USSR, on communism. There are pamphlets, there are letters from the Communist Party of the USA, from the Socialist Workers' Party, lots of stuff from the Fair Play for Cuba committee, which is a kind of far left group that is saying that the US has been very hard on Fidel Castro and stuff. They also find a Soviet passport with Lee Harvey Oswald's name and photo. Which, you know, I mean, that must be quite a shock because that's not the kind of thing you normally expect to find in Dallas, is it? No, no, not at all. An American citizen with a Soviet passport. That would have come as no surprise to the FBI. But it would to
警察来说呢？是的，但对警察来说。或者他们会被举报吗？不，他们可能不会。我的意思是，联邦调查局和达拉斯警方之间有很多沟通。即使在这个阶段，他们也在互相交谈。但当然，一个普通的达拉斯警官并不知道李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德是一个在苏联待过一段时间、一直被联邦调查局监视的人等等。回到詹姆斯·邦德，令人惊奇的是，你有这些看起来完全不可信的间谍惊悚片，涉及冷战诡计。然后你发现了那个被怀疑用苏联护照射杀美国总统的人。我的意思是，那种你身处戏剧之中、身处剧本之中的感觉，一定非常强烈，我想。嗯，汤姆，那个故事的进一步转折实际上是，詹姆斯·邦德书籍销量最大的增长是在约翰·F·肯尼迪说他喜欢读伊恩·弗莱明（Ian Fleming）的书的时候。他提到了，我想是《来自俄罗斯的爱》（From Russia With Love），作为他最喜欢的书之一。因为他当然正是那种人，二战的产物，在某些方面，文化上相当保守，那些书的目标读者。他是那种觉得读这些书很有趣的人。
the police, would it? Yeah, but to the police. Or would they have been tipped off? No, they probably wouldn't have been. I mean, there's a lot of communication between the FBI and the Dallas police. Even at this stage, they are talking to each other. But of course, an ordinary Dallas police officer doesn't know that Lee Harvey Oswald is a man who has spent time in the Soviet Union and that he's been watched by the FBI and so on and so forth. Just to go back to the James Bond, it is amazing that you have these spy thrillers that seem entirely implausible, that involve Cold War shenanigans. And then you find the guy who is suspected of shooting the President of the
但这个故事的全部，我的意思是，它是实际事件与当时的高层政治和戏剧性被改写为虚构作品之间的接口。是的。
United States with a Soviet pulse ball. I mean, the sense that you are inside a drama, you're inside a script, must have been overpowering, I'd have thought. Well, the further twist to that, Tom, actually, is that the single biggest boost in the sales of the James Bond books was when John F. Kennedy said that he loved reading the In Fleming books. And he named, I think it was From Russia With Love as one of his favorite books. Because he is, of course, precisely the kind of person, a product of World War II, in some ways, sort of culturally quite conservative, that those books are aimed at. He's that sort of person who finds them a fun read.
而且这是一个融合点，将在未来几十年里产生涟漪。虚构与事实的关系。是的，这是一个非常公平的观点。五点钟，空军一号终于降落在马里兰州的安德鲁斯空军基地（Andrews Air Force Base），
But the whole thing with this story, I mean, it's the interface between actual events and the way in which the high politics and the drama of the time has been rewritten as fiction. Yeah.
在华盛顿特区外，被遇害总统的兄弟罗伯特（Robert）迎接，他是负责执法的司法部长。他当然一直在严厉打击黑手党。他当然是。谈到过那个。他接到过J·埃德加·胡佛打到他家的电话，告诉他他的兄弟被枪击身亡。这两个人合不来，对吧？
And that this is a kind of a fusion point that will ripple through the decades to come. The relationship of fiction and fact. Yeah, that's a very fair point. Five o'clock, Air Force One finally lands at Andrews Air Force Base in Maryland, which
他们一点也合不来。罗伯特·肯尼迪完全忠于他的兄弟。他把自己的职业生涯从属于他的兄弟。他基本上非常乐意成为他兄弟的硬汉，成为他兄弟好警察形象背后的坏警察。而且他，我的意思是，任何兄弟当然都会感到崩溃，但他悲痛到了极点的程度。他基本上因为他兄弟的遇刺而陷入了巨大的中年危机和抑郁。所以他去接飞机。约翰·F·肯尼迪的遗体被送往贝塞斯达海军医院进行尸检。林登·约翰逊被直接带到白宫。多米尼克，我能说一下关于LBJ的事吗？我的意思是，他的名声是他是一个硬汉，
is outside Washington, D.C., and it is met there by the slain president's brother, Robert, who is the attorney general in charge of law enforcement. And who has been going hard after the mafia, of course. He has, of course. Talked about that. He had had a call at his house from J. Edgar Hoover to tell him that his brother had been shot and killed. The two men don't get on, do they?
在华盛顿特区外，遇害总统的弟弟、负责执法的司法部长罗伯特在那里迎接灵柩。当然，他一直对黑手党采取强硬态度。他当然是这样。谈到这一点，他曾在家里接到J·埃德加·胡佛的电话，告知他哥哥被枪杀的消息。这两个人关系不好，对吧？
They don't get on at all. Robert Kennedy is totally devoted to his brother. He has subordinated his career to his brothers. He has basically been very happy to be his brother's hard man, to be a bad cop to his brother's good cop. And he, I mean to be his brother's hard man, to be a bad cop to his brother's good cop. And he, I mean, any brother is, of course, would be devastated, but he is stricken to an extraordinary degree. He basically goes into this colossal midlife crisis and depression as a result of his brother's assassination. So he meets the plane. John F. Kennedy's body is taken to Bethesda Naval Hospital for the autopsy. Lyndon Johnson is taken straight to the White House. Dominic, can I just say about LBJ who, I mean, his rap is that he's a hard man,
他们一点也不合。罗伯特·肯尼迪对他哥哥极其忠诚。他将自己的事业置于哥哥的事业之下。他基本上很乐意做哥哥的“硬汉”，在哥哥扮演“好警察”时充当“坏警察”。我的意思是，任何兄弟遇到这种情况当然都会悲痛欲绝，但他受到的打击程度非同寻常。由于哥哥遇刺，他基本上陷入了巨大的中年危机和抑郁之中。所以他去接机。约翰·F·肯尼迪的遗体被送往贝塞斯达海军医院进行尸检。林登·约翰逊被直接带往白宫。多米尼克，关于LBJ，我能说一下吗？我的意思是，人们对他的评价是他是个硬汉，
often very brutal in his personal relations with people. The first thing that he does when he gets to the White House is to write letters to Kennedy's two children. So, dear John, it will be many years before you understand fully what a great man your father was. His loss is a deep personal tragedy for all of us, but I wanted you particularly to know that I share your grief. You can always be proud of him. And then to Caroline, your father's death has been a great tragedy for the nation as well as for you at this time. He was a wise and devoted man. You can always be proud of what he did for his country. I mean, it's very moving, I think. I think it is moving.
在处理人际关系时往往非常冷酷。他进入白宫后做的第一件事，就是给肯尼迪的两个孩子写信。亲爱的约翰，要过很多年你才能完全理解你的父亲是多么伟大的人。他的离世对我们所有人来说都是一场深重的个人悲剧，但我特别想让你知道，我分担着你的悲伤。你永远可以为他感到骄傲。然后是对卡罗琳说，你父亲的去世对国家和你个人来说都是一场巨大的悲剧。他是一位睿智而忠诚的人。你永远可以为你父亲为国家所做的一切感到骄傲。我的意思是，我认为这非常感人。我认为这确实很感人。
Well, LBJ, like a lot of quite hard men, is quite sentimental, I think, in some ways. Now, LBJ afterwards got a terribly bad rap, actually, from the Kennedy court, if you like, because he made changes. He kicked out some people. He kept others. He kicks out the Secretary, doesn't he, straight away? He does. Gives her half an hour to clear her desk. He gets a bad rap and people say he was very insensitive to jackie
嗯，林登·约翰逊（LBJ）和许多性格刚硬的人一样，在某些方面其实相当感性。后来，林登·约翰逊实际上受到了肯尼迪核心圈子非常糟糕的评价，因为他做出了一些改变。他解雇了一些人，留下了另一些人。他直接解雇了秘书，不是吗？是的。只给了她半小时收拾办公桌。他因此名声不佳，人们说他对杰奎琳非常不体贴。
he couldn't wait to you know clear out all their stuff and all this kind of thing this is actually not right at all there are lots of accounts of people who say actually on the plane and afterwards he was conscious of the awkwardness of his position and very solicitous of mrs kennedy and when he gets back isn't he reproached? Is it by Bob McKinney? I can't remember. And LBJ accepts it. Yeah.
他迫不及待地想清理掉他们的东西之类的，但这其实完全不对。有很多人的叙述都说，实际上在飞机上和之后，他很清楚自己处境的尴尬，对肯尼迪夫人非常关切。当他回来时，他不是受到了指责吗？是鲍勃·麦金尼吗？我不记得了。但林登·约翰逊接受了。是的。
For pushing things too fast. Yeah. And he kind of reigns back. He's in an impossible position. Tom, whatever he had done. Of course. People would have found things to criticise. I think there is lots to criticise Lyndon Johnson for generally, but his conduct after
因为他行事太急。是的。他稍微收敛了一些。他处于一种不可能的境地，汤姆，无论他做什么，当然，人们总会找到批评他的理由。我认为林登·约翰逊在很多方面确实值得批评，但在……之后他的表现
the assassination, I think, is for somebody in shock who's been catapulted into this office, as far as he knows, there may be assassins out for him too. I think it's incredibly harsh to criticize him. Unless, of course, he's behind the conspiracy. Unless, of course, he knows something about the conspiracy, which we will come to. In Dallas, Lee Harvey Oswald has been taken to the police station. He is already under interrogation. He's being interrogated by a guy called Captain J.W. Fritz. He's a very impressive seeming man.
暗杀事件发生后，我认为对于一个处于震惊中、突然被推上这个职位的人来说，据他所知，可能还有刺客在针对他。我认为批评他太苛刻了。除非，当然，他是阴谋的幕后黑手。除非他知道关于阴谋的一些内情，我们稍后会谈到。在达拉斯，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德已被带到警察局。他已经在接受审讯了。审讯他的人叫J.W.弗里茨警长。他看起来是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。
Yeah, a very experienced Dallas policeman. Expert interrogator, isn't he? Yeah, very calm. He likes to create a kind of- A bond. Relationship, of course, with the suspect. Yeah. It is obvious right from the beginning to all of the people around oswald that he is put it this way none of them have any doubts they have the right man and
是的，一位非常有经验的达拉斯警察。审讯专家，对吧？是的，非常冷静。他喜欢建立一种……一种纽带。当然，与嫌疑人建立关系。是的。从一开始，奥斯瓦尔德周围的所有人都很明显，他们认为……换句话说，他们没有人怀疑抓错了人，而且
the reason they don't have any doubts is that he doesn't really make much of an effort to protest his innocence so he says i didn't do it but he says it in this kind of sullen withdrawn snarky kind of teenager being rude to his parents kind of way correct everybody i mean the assistant dallas da guy called bill alexander he says what struck me is that oswald always acted like he was in control it was as though everything was rehearsed he was arrogant and defiant with fritz he said i found his whole behavior completely inappropriate to the situation now the thing is if you were tom yes you know when we go on one of our rest is history tours if you with Fritz. He said, I found his whole behavior completely inappropriate to the situation. Now, the thing is, if you were, Tom, when we go on one of our Restless History tours,
他们之所以没有怀疑，是因为他并没有真正努力去证明自己的清白。他说“我没做”，但他说话的方式就像那种阴沉、孤僻、尖酸刻薄的青少年在对父母无礼。没错，每个人都这么说。达拉斯助理地方检察官比尔·亚历山大说，让他印象深刻的是，奥斯瓦尔德表现得好像一切尽在掌握，就好像一切都排练过一样。他对弗里茨傲慢且挑衅。他说，我发现他的整个行为与当时的情况完全不符。现在的问题是，如果你是汤姆，是的，你知道当我们进行“历史余韵”巡回演出时，如果你和弗里茨在一起。他说，我发现他的整个行为与当时的情况完全不符。现在的问题是，如果你是，汤姆，当我们进行“历史余韵”巡回演出时，
if you are unjustly accused, I would not expect you to behave in such a way. I don't expect you to- No, I wouldn't be sulky. No. I'd be sobbing. You'd either be sobbing or you would be furious, wouldn't you? No, I'd be sobbing. Would you? Oh, Tom. I'm a sobber. Okay. Well, I mean, let's hope you never have to.
如果你被不公正地指控，我不会指望你表现得那样。我不指望你……不，我不会阴沉着脸。不，我会痛哭流涕。你要么会痛哭流涕，要么会暴跳如雷，不是吗？不，我会痛哭流涕。你会吗？哦，汤姆。我是个爱哭鬼。好吧，我的意思是，希望你永远不必经历这些。
Yeah, let's hope this is all very academic. Yeah. So as the afternoon becomes the evening, they're still interrogating Oswald, and he is still denying everything. And muttering about his rights, he says he wants a particular lawyer who is associated with the American Civil Liberties Union, the ACLU. That's in New York, isn't it? Yeah, from New York.
是的，希望这一切都只是纸上谈兵。是的。随着下午变成傍晚，他们仍在审讯奥斯瓦尔德，而他仍然否认一切。他嘟囔着自己的权利，说他想要一位与美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）有关联的特定律师。那是在纽约，对吧？是的，来自纽约。
He's got this one particular lawyer. I can't remember the guy's name and they never get through to him and that is all oswald can ever go on about is this one particular guy now meanwhile an unexpected person pitches up at dallas police headquarters and this is a man called jack ruby and jack ruby is a nightclub owner um his original name is jacob rubenstein He's from Chicago. He was born in 1911, so he's in his early 50s. Jack Ruby has an interesting story. He's from a kind of Polish, Orthodox Jewish family. He was one of 10 children, very troubled background. He was a delinquent. His parents had a violent relationship. His mother suffered from poor mental health he was in and out of foster homes he'd
他认准了这一位特定的律师。我不记得那人的名字了，他们一直没能联系上他，而奥斯瓦尔德一直念叨的就是这个人。与此同时，一个意想不到的人出现在达拉斯警察总部，这个人叫杰克·鲁比。杰克·鲁比是一位夜总会老板，嗯，他原名叫雅各布·鲁宾斯坦。他来自芝加哥。他出生于1911年，所以他五十出头。杰克·鲁比的故事很有趣。他来自一个波兰裔正统犹太家庭。他是十个孩子之一，背景非常坎坷。他曾是个问题少年。他的父母关系暴力。他的母亲患有精神疾病，他进出过多家寄养家庭，他曾
worked as an aircraft mechanic in world war ii but he is by every account an extremely erratic odd hot-tempered very emotional man isn't he he's always crying isn't he tom yeah i mean he really is a sobber yeah so he opens these various nightclubs and sort of strip clubs and things which of course in the run of things they have links you know people to do with organized crime will come to the clubs and he will give them drinks and he will talk to them. As he does to the police as well doesn't he? He loves the police and he's always giving them free drinks. He seems like a kind of detective monke. Yes. There seems to be a kind of intense feeling of identification with the police. Yeah.
在二战期间做过飞机机械师，但据所有人的描述，他是一个极其反复无常、古怪、脾气暴躁且非常情绪化的人，不是吗？他总是哭，不是吗，汤姆？是的，我的意思是，他确实是个爱哭鬼。是的，所以他开了几家夜总会和脱衣舞俱乐部之类的，当然，在经营过程中，他们会有联系，你知道，有组织犯罪的人会来俱乐部，他会给他们酒喝，会和他们聊天。就像他对待警察一样，不是吗？他热爱警察，总是给他们免费的酒喝。他看起来像个侦探迷。是的。他似乎对警察有一种强烈的认同感。是的。
And I guess the sense of a path that he can't take. Yeah. Bit like Elvis with Nixon. He'd love a badge. Like Elvis with Nixon. I think that's a nice comparison. Yeah. He loves the glamour of the police and he likes the sort of sense of authority and status
我想这是一种他无法实现的路径感。是的。有点像猫王和尼克松。他很想要一枚徽章。就像猫王和尼克松。我认为这是一个很好的类比。是的。他热爱警察的魅力，喜欢那种权威和地位感
that comes with the police, the camaraderie. He likes to think he's one of the boys what is important to say about jack ruby jack ruby is not part of organized crime organized crime people will go to his clubs he will give them drinks he will chat to them he will be friendly he is the last person that a serious organized crime group would want anything to do with it, because he's going to start crying, shouting. He does things like he takes his top off at inappropriate moments and things.
随之而来的还有那种同志情谊。他喜欢认为自己是他们的一员。关于杰克·鲁比，重要的一点是，杰克·鲁比不是有组织犯罪的一部分。有组织犯罪的人会去他的俱乐部，他会给他们酒喝，会和他们聊天，会很友好。他是严肃的有组织犯罪集团最不想打交道的人，因为他会开始哭泣、大喊大叫。他会做一些在不恰当的时候脱掉上衣之类的事情。
He's just so eccentric and weird that you wouldn't want to rely on such a man. But against that, I mean, on the more positive side, if you wanted a corned beef sandwich, he'd be your man, wouldn't he? Because he's always bringing people corned beef sandwiches when he hears the news about canada's assassination what is it celery fruit juice a celery tonic tom celery dominic i so i read that and i thought oh that's a sandbrook tipple if ever i've heard one
他太古怪、太奇怪了，你不会想依赖这样一个人。但反过来说，我的意思是，从积极的一面来看，如果你想吃一个咸牛肉三明治，他会是你的不二人选，不是吗？因为当他听到肯尼迪遇刺的消息时，他总是给人们带咸牛肉三明治。那是什么？芹菜果汁？芹菜补品，汤姆。芹菜，多米尼克。我读到这个时想，哦，如果我听说过的话，那绝对是桑德布鲁克的嗜好。
i wouldn't thank you i don't believe any vegetable should be made into a drink. I don't like vegetable smoothies or anything of that kind. The idea of drinking a bit of celery, it's anathema to me, Tom. It's against all I stand for. He brings it to the police and they all say, oh, this is the best soft drink we've ever had. So the Dallas police would disagree with you. I think they're being kind.
我可不敢当，我不相信任何蔬菜都应该被做成饮料。我不喜欢蔬菜冰沙或任何类似的东西。喝芹菜汁的想法对我来说是深恶痛绝的，汤姆。这违背了我所坚持的一切。他把它带给警察，他们都说，哦，这是我们喝过的最好的软饮料。所以达拉斯警察会不同意你的看法。我想他们只是客气一下。
I don't see a Dallas policeman. Maybe I'm stereotyping the police of the great city of dallas and the great state of texas but i don't see them as celery tonic drinkers tom anyway i don't know i think texas i think celery tonic so jack ruby when he hears the news of kennedy's death he bursts into tears everybody says he's in a terrible state he's actually been in a rage anyway because he had seen that advert that we talked about in the last episode in the Dallas Morning News.
我没见过达拉斯警察。也许我对伟大的达拉斯市和伟大的德克萨斯州的警察有刻板印象，但我没把他们看作是喝芹菜补品的人，汤姆。不管怎样，我不知道，我想德克萨斯，我想芹菜补品。所以杰克·鲁比听到肯尼迪去世的消息时，他泪流满面。每个人都说他状态很糟糕。其实他本来就在发火，因为他看到了我们在上一集谈到的《达拉斯晨报》上的那则广告。
Signed by that guy, Bernard Weissman, basically saying that Kennedy was a communist. And that had really inflamed him. He loves the Kennedys. What he's inflamed about is the fact that the guy who signed the advert has a Jewish surname. And he says they're trying to frame the Jews and make us out to be Kennedy haters.
由那个叫伯纳德·魏斯曼的人签署，基本上说肯尼迪是共产主义者。这真的激怒了他。他热爱肯尼迪。让他愤怒的是，签署广告的人有一个犹太姓氏。他说他们试图陷害犹太人，让我们看起来像是肯尼迪的仇恨者。
I love Kennedy. Kennedy is the best man in the country. So when he hears that he's dead, he's crying, he's ringing people and all of this. And he hears that the Dallas police have arrested a suspect. And his instinct is, oh, our brave boys. Crack open the celery tonic. I'll take them some corned beef sandwiches, which he does. Unbelievably, I mean, the laxness, I suppose you would say, by modern standards.
我爱肯尼迪。肯尼迪是这个国家最好的人。所以当他听说他死了，他在哭，他在给人们打电话，所有这些。他听说达拉斯警方逮捕了一名嫌疑人。他的本能是，哦，我们勇敢的小伙子们。打开芹菜补品。我要给他们带些咸牛肉三明治，他也确实这么做了。难以置信，我的意思是，以现代标准来看，这种松懈程度。
He is able to walk right into the police station with all these sandwiches. And he actually, at one point, he's poised to go into Captain Fritz's office, where Lee Harvey Oswald is being interrogated with all these sandwiches and drinks. And somebody says, oh, no, Jack, you can't go in there. So he doesn't go in. But that will give the listeners a sense of what they would now regard, I suppose, as amateurishness, that people are able to just stroll around. But of course, at the time, it doesn't occur to them.
他能够带着所有这些三明治直接走进警察局。而且在某个时刻，他准备走进弗里茨警长的办公室，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德正在那里接受审讯，他带着所有这些三明治和饮料。有人说，哦，不，杰克，你不能进去。所以他没进去。但这会让听众感受到他们现在会认为的业余，人们竟然可以随意走动。但当然，在当时，他们并没有意识到这一点。
I mean, the press are all packed in and shouting. But also because they haven't lived through the whole JFK shenanigans. Exactly. So they're not alert to all the things that can happen. Exactly. Lost innocence, Dominic. And I think also they're the first generation to live with television and the media age and mass media. And the idea that the news of this can be communicated so quickly
我的意思是，媒体都挤在一起大喊大叫。但也因为他们没有经历过整个肯尼迪遇刺的闹剧。没错。所以他们对可能发生的所有事情并不警觉。没错。失去的纯真，多米尼克。而且我认为他们也是第一代生活在电视、媒体时代和大众媒体中的人。关于这个消息可以传播得如此之快
and that people can come piling into the police station. Because it's interesting that people are aware of the kind of the chaos, the misinformation that followed Lincoln's assassination. Yeah. But none of that lives in our imagining. No. Because it's all in faded newsprint. But the Kennedy assassination does.
人们可以涌入警察局。因为有趣的是，人们意识到林肯遇刺后出现的混乱和错误信息。是的。但这些都没有存在于我们的想象中。不。因为那都在褪色的新闻纸上。但肯尼迪遇刺事件却存在。
Because, as you say, it's all on film. It's hurtling around the world. So just to go back to the interrogation of Oswald, by about 9.30 that evening, Captain Fritz, the homicide investigator, who you rightly say, Tom, comes out of this story. I think, unless you think he's part of a conspiracy, I think Captain Fritz is a very impressive person. Well, there is a very suspicious aspect to Captain Fritz. Okay. I know what it is. i know what it is i know what it is and i think if his if his relatives or descendants are listening they will be
因为正如你所说，这一切都在胶片上。它在全世界飞速传播。所以回到对奥斯瓦尔德的审讯，大约那天晚上9点30分，凶杀案调查员弗里茨警长，正如你正确指出的，汤姆，他从这个故事中脱颖而出。我认为，除非你认为他是阴谋的一部分，否则我认为弗里茨警长是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。好吧，弗里茨警长有一个非常可疑的地方。好吧。我知道是什么。我知道是什么，我知道是什么，我想如果他的亲戚或后代在听的话，他们会
you know we will see i mean tom if you go to dallas they'll have you sobbing in their cell that's all i'm going to say well i'm just i'm not going to say i believe it anyway let's park this and carry on with the narrative so captain fritz this, this is what he has. He has Oswald on the sixth floor of the Texas Book Depository a few minutes before the shooting. He has the fact that they have found cartridges, they have found the paper bag, and they have now found the rifle on the sixth floor.
你知道我们会看到的，我的意思是汤姆，如果你去达拉斯，他们会让你在牢房里痛哭流涕，我只想说这些。好吧，我只是……我不会说我相信它。不管怎样，让我们搁置这个，继续叙述。所以弗里茨警长，这就是他所掌握的。他在枪击前几分钟，在德克萨斯州教科书仓库大楼的六楼发现了奥斯瓦尔德。他掌握的事实是，他们发现了弹壳，发现了纸袋，现在还在六楼发现了步枪。
He has the fact that Oswald's wife Marina, who is Russian, says that he owned a rifle. And this looks like the rifle they have. There's a possibility they will have some sort of print on the rifle as it turns out they get a palm print but not fingerprints fritz also knows that oswald is the only employee of the texas book depository who left the building after the shooting and did not return. He also has the fact that Oswald, almost certainly in their mind,
他掌握的事实是，奥斯瓦尔德的俄罗斯妻子玛丽娜说他拥有一支步枪。这看起来就像他们拥有的那支步枪。他们有可能在步枪上留下某种指纹，事实证明他们得到了一个掌纹，但没有指纹。弗里茨还知道，奥斯瓦尔德是枪击后离开大楼且没有返回的唯一一名德克萨斯州教科书仓库员工。他还掌握的事实是，奥斯瓦尔德，在他们看来几乎可以肯定，
well, indeed, certainly in their minds, is the man who killed Officer J.D. Tippett a little while later. So by 11.20 that night, when he gathers with the attorneys and his men, they are all agreed. They think there is enough evidence to charge Lee Harvey Oswald
嗯，确实，在他们看来，是稍后杀害J.D.蒂皮特警官的人。所以到了那天晚上11点20分，当他与律师和手下聚集时，他们都达成了一致。他们认为有足够的证据起诉李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德
with the murder of the president. And a little bit later, they do something absolutely unprecedented. They bring Oswald out to the media as a spectacle in the full glare of the world's media. And this seems an extraordinary thing to do when you are only just building your case. And so this is what, just after midnight? Yeah. But of course, the reason why they do it, as Vincent Bugliosi describes in his book on this, and I think he's absolutely right, is that for the police chief, it is really
谋杀总统。稍后，他们做了一件绝对前所未有的事情。他们把奥斯瓦尔德带到媒体面前，作为一场奇观，暴露在全世界媒体的聚光灯下。当你刚刚建立起你的案件时，这似乎是一件非同寻常的事情。所以这是什么，午夜刚过？是的。但当然，他们这样做的原因，正如文森特·布格里奥西在他的书中描述的那样，而且我认为他是完全正确的，对于警察局长来说，这确实
important to be open with the world. Yeah. For decades, there have been situations where there have been hard-bitten reporters in dirty Macintoshes. Gumshoes. Yeah, gumshoes, standing around with a battered old bit of pencil and a piece of paper. But they've never had a moment like this with television cameras.
对世界保持开放很重要。是的。几十年来，一直有穿着脏雨衣的顽强记者。私家侦探。是的，私家侦探，拿着破旧的铅笔和纸站在那里。但他们从未有过像电视摄像机这样的时刻。
I love the journalist who rushes into the phone box, you know, seconds after the assassination and then just reads things out very, very slowly so that no one else can get into it. That's very gumshoe behaviour. It is very gumshoe behavior it is very gumshoe so they bring oswald out the cameras the flashbulbs are going the cameras are whirring it's actually a bit of a non-event this press conference oswald gives very weak and boring answers and he evades most of the questions and just sort of mutters about his rights and whatever yeah he doesn't know what's going on and all this kind of thing and then the da is
我喜欢那个冲进电话亭的记者，你知道，在暗杀发生几秒钟后，然后非常非常缓慢地读出东西，这样其他人就进不去了。那是典型的私家侦探行为。这确实是典型的私家侦探行为。所以他们把奥斯瓦尔德带出来，摄像机、闪光灯在闪烁，摄像机在转动。这次新闻发布会实际上有点平淡无奇。奥斯瓦尔德给出的回答非常软弱和无聊，他回避了大部分问题，只是嘟囔着他的权利之类的。是的，他不知道发生了什么，所有这些事情。然后地方检察官是
guy called henry wade the district attorney he steps forward he starts talking about oswald and at one point he misnames the fair play for cuba committee which oswald has been connected to he says oh i don't know what it is it's the defense of cuba or something like this and a man shouts out from the back and says no it's it's the Fair Play for Cuba committee. And the guy who does this is Jack Ruby. Yeah. So he's given them his corned beef sandwiches and the celery tonics,
一个叫亨利·韦德的人，地方检察官，他走上前，开始谈论奥斯瓦尔德。在某个时刻，他叫错了奥斯瓦尔德与之有关联的“公平竞争古巴委员会”的名字。他说，哦，我不知道那是什么，是“保卫古巴”之类的。后面有人大喊，说不，是“公平竞争古巴委员会”。做这件事的人是杰克·鲁比。是的。所以他给了他们咸牛肉三明治和芹菜补品，
and now he's just been lurking around Ruby in the basement. So he's just feet away from Oswald. And you can see that bit on YouTube where Ruby shouts out, a man shouts out. Anyway, the press conference breaks up. It was all a bit desultory. Ruby goes back home. He's calling people and crying and saying, poor Mrs. Kennedy, her poor children, what
现在他只是在地下室里潜伏着。所以他离奥斯瓦尔德只有几英尺远。你可以在YouTube上看到鲁比大喊的那一段，一个人大喊。不管怎样，新闻发布会解散了。一切都有点杂乱无章。鲁比回家了。他在给人们打电话，哭着说，可怜的肯尼迪夫人，她可怜的孩子们，发生了什么
a terrible thing to happen. So he's gone home and he's driving everybody mad. Oswald is held at police headquarters in the cell. LBJ and Jackie are back in Washington DC and there's one more development overnight Tom which is that at four o'clock in the morning the FBI managed to trace the rifle it's a Manlica Carcano rifle and they trace it to a shop called Klein's Sporting Goods in Chicago and it was a mail order rifle. So you would see an advert and you would write in and you would send a money order to get it delivered. And the name of the customer who
可怕的事情。所以他回家了，把每个人都逼疯了。奥斯瓦尔德被关在警察总部的牢房里。林登·约翰逊和杰奎琳回到了华盛顿特区，汤姆，一夜之间还有一个进展，那就是凌晨四点，联邦调查局设法追踪到了那支步枪，那是一支曼利夏-卡尔卡诺步枪，他们追踪到了芝加哥一家叫克莱恩体育用品的商店，那是一支邮购步枪。所以你会看到一则广告，你会写信，你会寄汇票来让它送达。客户的名字是
had ordered the rifle was A. Heidel of Dallas, Texas. And that is, of course, the second of the two names that was in Lee Harvey Oswald's wallet. So, so many conspiracies, so much to discuss, so far still to go. Don't say that. So, well, I think this must be the first time that we've done two podcasts on a single day. Yeah. And we still have lots more to come because of extraordinary developments, which in turn will feed into the great swirl of conspiracy theories. So we will be continuing this story. If you would like to find out what happens, here are opinions on who really shot JFK.
订购步枪的是德克萨斯州达拉斯的A.海德尔。当然，这就是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德钱包里的两个名字中的第二个。所以，太多的阴谋，太多的讨论，还有很长的路要走。别这么说。所以，好吧，我想这一定是我们第一次在同一天做两个播客。是的。而且我们还有更多内容要讲，因为非同寻常的进展，这反过来又会助长阴谋论的漩涡。所以我们将继续这个故事。如果你想知道发生了什么，这里有关于谁真正射杀肯尼迪的观点。
You can access all the episodes in this series right now by going to therestishistory.com. But whether you want to do that or whether you want to wait, we will see you very soon. And we will be back with the events of the 23rd of November and the two days that follow that. So we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
你可以通过访问therestishistory.com立即获取本系列的所有剧集。但无论你是想现在就看，还是想等一等，我们很快就会再见。我们将带着11月23日及其后两天的事件回来。所以我们到时候见。再见。再见。再见。问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。